so we built in a billion dollar decent
business
uh out of networking lands yeah land
solutions
[Music]
gil frosting thank you so much for being
on 20 minute leaders
my pleasure so good to have you i'm used
to seeing you once a month at the j
ventures at the j ventures monthly
meeting where you're also an lp
and so now we have to do this uh no now
we have to do this
uh online like this and but actually
you're more than an lpnd adventurers but
you're actually taking a much more of a
chief technology uh role correct
yeah i'm pretty active there i like it a
lot
to be to be a sort of a chief technology
officer of a fund like
j ventures what does that even mean that
makes me very proud
actually um i i really like the whole
concept of j ventures used to be called
j
engines prior to that i think it's a
model
of a vc second to none
there are some things here which are so
unique um
and we're gonna do great business one
hand but also at the same time we're
gonna
feel the culture okay of the community
that is gonna be first of its kind so
a capitalistic keyboard so i've been
stealing that sentence from quite a few
people
yeah we only have 19 minutes left i'm
already upset uh
so much to cover uh you word until
since graduating from the tiffany on
spent 30 years then
30 years there climbed the ladder of
success from an entry-level chip
designer to a vp
moved out onto qualcomm and built
products that emerged as number one in
the market of bluetooth and wi-fi you're
gonna explain to me what that means
and now you're in silicon valley one of
the most well respected advisors board
members
and investors take me back technion
you graduate and and you're entering
intel
what is that like spending 30 years at
the company and climbing up the ladder
of success
well first of all intel has been a
fantastic company for me
it is a big company so actually i got
opportunities here and there
okay it was always under you know for 30
years it was under
under the intel umbrella i call it but
they were very different things
so i did start as a chip design guy in
haifa
and over time i moved to the us
and i got a great opportunity to be a
co-gm of a business unit
there um and this really opened a lot of
opportunities for me
and i was i guess very lucky
which is a big part of the story what is
it like um
fighting for those ranks because you
know at least you know young
entrepreneurs like myself all we hear
about is
yeah you could join a company like intel
ibm google et cetera and then slowly
climb the ladder but that's really hard
why don't you go
do a startup get acquired maybe and then
just join as a director
i mean talk to me about your experience
i don't think there's one answer which
fits everyone
yeah uh some people are really born to
be in startups
okay this is their personality of course
we know the percentage of successes of
startups
um so somebody wants to try and
you know generate some calculation they
may but it doesn't mean anything
did you know did you think you're going
to get to where you got to it until
i get opportunities opportunities
which were far better than my dreams i
can tell you that
that's incredible yeah and i'm really
grateful for that
um and you know
i started the young engineer there were
very good people around me
okay and this gave me a huge push
uh true teamwork okay
uh which intel israel was
built on the shoulders of several you
know very good people who just
created the culture and we were helping
each other
um and it was you know just a fantastic
start for my career
and then actually people in haifa helped
me
get to the um opportunity i got it until
in the u.s it started in oregon
uh in the land business okay and i got
to be a
ogm there which was phenomenal
experience for me
ogm is sorry
ogm what what is that code gm okay
language it's called the two in a box um
so i was mostly the operations and the
engineering person
and i had a person and i had a partner
who was mostly
marketing and sales and together we
built a strategy and
working on the budgets and the
leadership of the organization
we actually grew an organization which
was about 250 billion dollars
over three years in the late 90s
uh to become my one billion dollar
organization
wow and so you know each person can have
opportunities different places
in excel at different places um
you know you know they say that if you
want to run a billion dollar business
yeah you should go be
an entrepreneur because that's really
the only way but no you said you
went the you know the intel route and
you you still got
to manage a billion dollar business wow
well the other
one of the other fortunes was i never
worked on an x86 processor with intel
i always worked on other businesses
which were new to intel so we built in a
billion dollar
decent business uh out of networking
lands
yeah land solutions then our team my
partner and i were assigned to build
this new protocol nobody heard of which
was wi-fi
why i've heard of that before yeah i
mean people try to
yeah people try to have wireless
solutions for a long time
but this was the right timing definitely
and we could
we are talking about the inception the
years where
the internet is born because you know
talking to somebody like me
i don't know what that means but but
there was a period
where the internet needed to be born and
and i get to be speaking now
to one of the pioneers who got it out of
the world
okay i'll buy that um
so i say i think the internet really
started to spread around in mid 90s
and in the late 90s we were assigned
to go and implement this uh you know new
wireless protocol
and uh folks in uh
worked in israel on ships for
plans i said hey can you do the same
thing just without the wire
and what do israelite engineers say of
course we can
so this was 98 or 99
and by 2003 we came out
with a solution wi-fi into the intel
platform which was called centrino
again you need to be half a dinosaur to
remember that name
uh and uh it became a real success
so this was actually together not only
the engineering efforts but also all the
marketing efforts
and the market creation effort um this
was actually the one
product and the one brand which opened
up the the wi-fi market
and later on it was so
gratifying to see people who
they just need wi-fi is the same as they
need oxygen to some extent
okay it became so pervasive you know
actually gil you mentioned that i was on
kilimanjaro a year ago with
exactly a year ago with my dad and my
brother we were up on the mountain
and we didn't have wi-fi but we had
oxygen and at some point i was
i was thinking why do i want more right
now i didn't have my wi-fi for a week
and
i didn't know what i valued more right
right
so this is very rewarding you know to
see how successful this became
um so i was just you know fortunate to
be part of that team
uh which was assigned to start it we
started something on the side
you know for intel suddenly they decided
to have it as
one of the key components on the
that was platform was a side project it
started as a side project
yeah it was something on the side for
this uh land
division maybe they can do something out
of it
and then the ceo of intel realized that
you know what
this could be one of the keystones here
for a new type of platform for intel
where we brand
not only the processor but we brand
several elements of the platform
the processor the networking the chips
uh the memory
you know things of that nature right um
and
with all the additional efforts on the
marketing side
it became you know uh you know a big hit
and this uh and this actually opened the
entire
wi-fi market out there what what do you
learn from that so having gone through
this experience you know i can look at
it in the in the textbook and say okay
so this is one of the key innovations
that really transformed people's lives
you experienced it so what do you learn
about what can you
teach me about organizations or about
you know innovation and entrepreneurship
from from this example of
of the of this wi-fi technology being
born out of these circumstances
yeah so i think there are sometimes
cases
where somebody high there starts
something without knowing even
if it's going to be something good or
not and you have to try that we also
tried dsl and it didn't go anywhere
we also tried the cable modem solution
for the pc and it didn't go anywhere
but we tried life we started wi-fi and
at some point in time there was a
key strategic decision by the ceo so
this was in my opinion
an example where ceo can decide on some
strategy which really makes a difference
okay um and because of that
from something on the side we just
joined the eye of the storm
okay and we had weekly meetings with the
ceo to make sure everything is on track
between
the field yeah wow so in the chipset and
the
processor and our solution and
everything else
a new pc platform is something pretty
complex and you don't want to be the guy
who's going to delay the new rollout of
a new platform
but it was you know and then there was
also
another element not about the design
which was about
enabling the market so the marketing
team came and said we're going to
build outside places coffee shops
you know 400 of them that will be
utilizing wi-fi so the ceo looked at
them and said why 400
why not 4 000 okay
and this was so meaningful and yes they
got to 4 000
and it really went terrifically from
there
and other companies also grew up in that
area
some of them think intel till today
because they became rich too
wow yeah very close that's incredible
and what does that mean
in building the platform that at the end
gets number one market share
and bluetooth and wi-fi technologies
well this this comes to
you know your work as a team and as a as
a pnl so
the trick income big companies like
intel they put people in business units
right people have a lot of affinity to
their own business
and they wanted to succeed in the
marketplace i i'll tell you the story
actually
about our gigabit ethernet controller
okay
land controller which we built around
the same time
and we competed head-to-head broadcom it
was
it was a huge battle okay
and it was just about
the question of who can do faster how
can we develop
it faster and high quality
at the end of it i remember till today
dell
was the king of the hill in pcs at that
time and we wanted
really bad to win dale and so did
broadcom
and the design win changed places
at dale between intel and broadcom five
times
last and fifth time was intel
okay this was one of the best days of my
career okay especially when you take
into account the guy who ran
rotcom at the time henry nicholas and
his eccentric behavior you can write
about it
you can read about it in the media in
the gossip columns wherever
you want to see it um but it was a
huge huge win wow right that's this is
incredible and gil you transitioned from
this then to
um you transitioned from that to silicon
valley helping companies
helping both early and late stage
companies succeed both at gig
capital where you're a strategic advisor
but also
but also as part of java interest so why
why why is that because you you
you go from these huge huge corporations
30 years
vp at until vp at qualcomm and all of a
sudden you're working with startups
yeah so um i've been in the valley here
for 20 years i still worked here for
intel
quite a bit and for uh qualcomm but
since the day i got here actually i
started to
get involved with startups i still found
the time
get engaged with startups usually they
came through my personal network
friends okay people from israel or
something like that right and
because i missed that i i really wanted
to learn
more about that and help where i get
where i could
and i found some great startups and
great people to work with
and over time i also learned to trade by
doing so
at some point in time i decided this was
about
two years ago i decided okay corporate
america was great for me
i'm thankful and uh
i want to do everything around startups
going forward
okay and i just uh you know i left i
went to pitch events speech
you know nights between samples in san
francisco
every day in different place just to
meet more people see more startups see
what i
learned see which one i can actually
help
you know i i started to be an advisor or
many of them invest
several of them um and then i had
uh you know then i found the other
ceremony and jay angels
were called at the time and this is you
know a
bunch of great people some of them are
vcs in the day job some of them are
ceos who are successful in driving their
companies
to exit corporate people
so it's a great mix and right now i feel
more comfortable
investing through or with
j ventures because uh i think we really
do a good job here on the
due diligence side as well as on the
connection side we are you know 160
members right now
and people are very connected and we can
not only
be investing and making money out of it
but we can actually help the startups
that we invest in
all the connections we have people in
the valley and we have people around the
world as well
so this became a very very positive
experience for me
i am mostly most of my time is about
startups
i met two new startups today earlier
okay um and it's it's wonderful
i love it nominal ideas okay
you see great people and you can help
them
right what what could be better tell me
a hundred percent no but but girl are
you
are you still in the you know hardcore
networking
scene or are you now branching out to
other things as well
i i did rent out branch out a lot uh
networking is one field if i can help
there it's
great but over the last 20 years i
really
learned a lot of things which are you
know relevant to many many types of
startups
right could be fintech could be biotech
medtech okay uh really lots of areas
i don't have anything smart to tell them
i don't tell them anything
but there's some some experience which
you know plays by now and
i can help really a lot of guys so so
you know give me some of those earned
secrets
over the years both as you know
corporate america but also as a startup
advisor
and and a strategic investor what what
are some what are some of the most
important things to keep in mind
especially you know considering the
times that we're at now and let's say
for early stage startups
what is the the common thing that you
see come up both the j ventures but
in other startups that you see that some
phenomenas
yeah so um there has to be some good
differentiation
now differentiation could be in the
technology or could be in the marketing
of it or
wherever but if you don't come with
something which is really new
and uh can gain you a lot of momentum
relative to competition
um it's gonna be very tough right it's
gonna be very very tough
uh people who are open to feedback
okay sometimes they need two people they
come with the people to their startups
and you know what it's a great idea i
mean not having a pivot every three
weeks but
um you know you listen to the market you
listen to customers you listen to other
people
you still have you know the initial
strength
of you and your team but you can say hey
you know what it could be more
applicable here
and i have also some connections so
this investor can give me more
connections in that area okay so
if they keep flexibility it helps a lot
right and i mean you know a lot of the
stores that we're seeing aj ventures a
lot of them are our early stage and
you can always you can always assume
that and throughout the lifetime of this
company
which hopefully will will end its
success there's going to be quite a few
pivots so
yeah a big part of also the due
diligence is understanding who are the
founders behind this
this right execution up to now and are
they flexible
to to pivot when necessary let's say
like in times of covet 19.
yes and the founders have to be very
also uh open to learning new things
because
right they're a first-time ceo
first-time cto
they have to understand the script and
how it evolves over time um
you know things like a lot of
presentations so i sit a lot with
companies on their presentation
for you know before angels or vcs
they tend to talk a lot about the
technology they tend to give a big big
background of how the world is changing
what are the new trends
well these things could be known already
or too deep technically and you have to
be a businessman
okay you have to understand that
the financials that you do here you plan
here
should be very very clear and
substantiated
okay and the entire story of how you
raise funds and all the ins and outs
uh that people uh really care when
they're investors
your personal story could be nice but
don't spend time on it
don't spend time on it these are
business people who sit in front of you
they want to see how you they they're
going to make 10x on your
on your uh startup but it's not cynical
it's a very good indic
it's a very good test okay
for you as well and you have to
understand the rules
and get into this uh you know very very
quickly
otherwise you're gonna be in love in
some of your slides which are not that
relevant
okay you're gonna waste people times and
then
you you're not going to have enough time
to extend the important things so after
two years of joy ventures after seeing
uh 200 startups in the last two years i
actually
wrote my own lists of slides and what
the
investor care about and i sit with
um i sit with ceos and help them
understand what they need to present
how they need to present it don't need
to rush
speaking too quickly okay
there's a lot to learn and you get one
shot get one shot that's it it has to be
perfect
sometimes people tend to wing it and
think it's okay
my invention is so smart everybody will
get it the answer is no they will not
get it
unless you really really simplify it and
explain it slowly
i love it gil i love it i love it i love
it but we have to we have to finish i
can't believe it's 20 minutes already
i have the most important question for
you er
three words that you would best describe
yourself as or
as anybody at j ventures would describe
gil frost against
um okay um
so i would say
first of all grateful okay finally
first of all grateful i think i've had a
hundred episodes i don't i don't
remember
uh grateful is being awarded yet okay
the other one is i love people
okay and i enjoy working with them okay
uh it's just you know just a dream for
me
and the other thing is uh try to be as
thorough as possible in this environment
definitely
definitely gil such a pleasure and thank
you for
all the everything that you're teaching
me at j ventures and here
and then i look forward to maintaining
this relationship and learning more from
you
thank you very much thank you thank you
for the stage here